at great big story we celebrate the bold  the fearless and the brave that subtle  Jota but I'm making up a promotional ad  shadow I have an assault come on si the  people who make our world richer  stronger and more beautiful my food is  influenced by the traditional books of  Mexico who create with cultural pride in  turn build relationships are very  powerful and people are now starting to  see that and understand I've always been  that people hate sad but that's reality  these are the fearless individuals who  stand proud in their identities I  haven't came but black eye refugee  people that share my identity you can be  proud all in the hopes of changing the  world these are the Rays